[Musique]
c'est un petit coin de paradis
des plages de sable fin une végétation
luxuriante la chaleur aux tropiques
l'île de sulawesi ou célèbes en
indonésie est une destination exotique
prisée
mais ce n'est pas ce qu'il y attirent
maximo vers le chercheur passe plutôt
son temps dans des sites peu couru des
touristes des grottes où il trouve des
trésors inestimables des peintures
tracés sont les murs de ces cavernes des
oeuvres millénaire parmi les plus
vieilles du monde
[Musique]
concédait qu'il y avait des peintures
l'on a fait et ce qui nous a poussé à
dire on avait vraiment c'est les dates
et c'était sur la plaie quand on a vu
les résultats la première fois
l'archéologue québécois maxime aubert et
professeur à l'université griffith en
australie depuis près de dix ans ces
découvertes font sans cesse reculer
l'âge des premières peintures rupestres
et nous force à revoir ce que nous
croyons comprendre de la naissance de
l'art et de la culture
l'an dernier il a décrit dans la revue
sayoud 7,26 ce dessin d'un an gül est
probablement un sanglier des célèbres
l'oeuvre tracé avec de locre à au moins
45 mille cinq cents ans l'homme moderne
il ya au moins 45 points 5/8 à milan et
est capable de faire des peintures en
fait très peu sophistiquée la grotte qui
abrite cette découverte se situe au pied
d'une montagne près d'un village
agricole
l'archipel indonésien regorge de
peintures préhistoriques à sulawesi rien
que dans la péninsule du sud ouest les
experts ont répertorié à ce jour près de
300 grottes ornées
maxime aubert a repensé lieu fabuleux
depuis 2012
fourmies en archéologie à l'université
laval le chercheur s'est ensuite
spécialisé en datation de l'art pariétal
à l'institut national de la recherche
scientifique inrs
avant de poursuivre ses recherches en
australie un jour son collègue adam brom
lui propose de l'accompagner dans ses
fouilles archéologiques en et denise qui
avait vu les peintures la bvk que tout
le monde pensait qu'ils étaient
relativement jeune mais lui il disait
lui en faisant défaut la baule il
trouvait plein d'or crous et dans le
temps des niveaux quand même assez vieux
donc il disait est ce que tu peux venir
voir donc je dirais je suis allé dans
quand j'ai pris des champions 2-0 menée
en australie où les adapter et puis
c'est ça que ça on a publié là en 2014
on a montré qu'on fait les peintures la
beauce ont il y avait au moins 40 milles
c'était la main marge reculer plié sur
un euro
la plupart des peintures indonésienne
représentent des mains en négatif ou des
animaux principalement des cochons
sauvages et des à noah et petits bovins
typique de la région
mais en 2018 maxime aubert tombe sur un
tableau inédit une grosse grotte en
dessous que j'avais dès jeudi cité mais
cette version un peu plus on prend de
faire cette échelle en bambou donc
monthey est logique du sol ouah donc
c'est pas juste des animaux en fait donc
une scène c'est une grande fresque de
quatre mètres et demi de large où des
petits personnages semblent retenir des
animaux avec des cordes rilance
peut-être une scène de chasse racontée
par nos ancêtres il y au moins 43 mille
neuf cent ans l'homme moderne on se
défie n'en fait comme une espèce qui me
se raconter des histoires en fait donc
ce qui nous différencie des autres c'est
qu'on raconte des histoires et ça en
fait c'est la plus vieille preuve jamais
trouverez
sur le tableau les figures sont mis
humaines mi animales ce que les
spécialistes appellent des terriens en
trope une statuette de terrien trope un
homme lion à peu près du même âge a été
découverte dans une grotte en allemagne
mais les peintures de terrien trope
connu en europe ont vingt mille ans de
montre que ça suggère c'est que l'homme
moderne aussi à ce moment là il y avait
la capacité de dépense des choses qu'ils
voyaient qui existait donc des choses
figurative mais il pourrait aussi
dépendre des choses qui n'existent pas
en fait c'est comme ça que les religions
comme ans
les âges plus que vénérable de ses
oeuvres sont loin d'être simple à
déterminer pour les évaluer les
scientifiques récolte de laquelle cit a
cumulé sur les parois de calcaire des
grottes au fil du temps dans ces dépôts
des atomes d'uranium se désintègre
naturellement en atomes de thorium un
rythme connu et constant un peu comme
avec la méthode du carbone 14 les
scientifiques peuvent alors mesuré l'âge
de ces dépôts au dessus de la peinture
laquelle six tonnes âge minimum de
l'oeuvre je vois sur le terrain du
groupe un échantillon et on se désole
oratoire après je le divise en trois ou
quatre sous-échantillon que sous des
champions qu'il est plus près de la
couche de peinture c'est le plus vieux
et le saladier plus jeunes dans la
surface donc cet échantillon lucky le
plus près la couche de personnes dont la
date minimum grâce à de nouvelles
techniques maxime aubert et ses
collègues tentent maintenant de
s'approcher au plus près de l'âge de la
peinture elle-même on sait que ces
couches de cassettes le ils se sont
formés par cat épisode n'ayant milliers
milliers d'épisodes au lieu des milliers
de cochons fait dedans
la coach qu'on ne peut recueillir en
quatre morceaux ce une moyenne de
plusieurs milliers de couches il utilise
un appareil au laser qui peut analyser
des couches de calcite à peine plus
épaisse qu'un cheveu et d'essai d'avoir
des couches les plus fine possible le
plus près possible la couche de peinture
ça ça nous donne déjà beaucoup plus dur
certaines peintures de l'archipel
indonésien pourrait bien être nettement
plus anciennes d'autant que plus au sud
en australie les plus vieilles traces de
présence humaine connue on 65 mille ans
et l'homme moderne est arrivé en
australie à 65 mille ans il faut que
soit passée par là donc on pense en fait
qu'on vous pour pousser à l'arrivée de
le modèle en asie du sud est
maxime aubert n'emploie pas l'expression
homme moderne à la légère pour lui ceux
qui ont réalisé ces oeuvres n'avait rien
à envier à leurs contemporains européens
car on a longtemps cru que les peintures
rupestres comme celles de lascaux de
chauvé en france témoignait de la
naissance de l'expression artistique en
europe qu'à changer complètement le
l'opinion que les gens pensaient à
l'époque que l'homme moderne est juste
devenue modèle quand quelqu'un est
arrivé en europe de l'ouest et qui
complètement hop l'art pariétal
indonésien amène donc les scientifiques
à réécrire au moins en partie notre
histoire en même temps en europe de
l'ouest et puis en asie du sud est les
gens faisaient en fait ces peintures
l'orchidée montrent en fait que l'homme
moderne était vraiment évolué donc
cognitivement moderne il ya au moins 45
3 5 millions ce que ça dit c'est que vu
ça n'arrive plus ou moins en même temps
ça veut dire que probablement quand le
modèle et seraient sortis d'afrique il y
aura peu près 65 mineurs 70 mineurs ils
étaient probablement coltineront moderne
en ce moment en plus d'analyser ses
peintures l'équipe de maxime au vert
entrepris des fouilles archéologiques
pour trouver des traces de ceux qui les
ont créés parce qu'à travers l'évolution
de l'art et de la culture c'est celle de
toute notre espèce qui se dessinent un
tableau à la fois